machen wir heute dollar
geht es doch nicht gleich etwas gedacht
und herz bekommt bei einem neuen video
ja heute ich habe es natürlich geht es
gut und zwar habe ich heute mal wieder
zugeschlagen ich habe mir gedacht
also wenn man sich mein outfit man
schaut und du-ri was fehlt was wäre
richtig geiles niki als ordnung man die
eisfelder die habe ich mir schon
bestellt auf jeden fall ich weiß nicht
ob ihr das video mit einem hula des
senats einwohner hatte fünf minuten zeit
und ist dabei so bestellen und hat unter
anderem 40 ganz viele klamotten bestellt
guck guck mal eine hose und so ist sie
doch so ganz gut aus zumindest auf den
fotos und rein damit ihr sitzt diese 3
damit kommt macht doch noch kurz ene
mene miste ist okay und in der ich die
zeit läuft ab du hast nach zwei minuten
und bedeuten allerdings aus südafrika
und dieses nica wollte ich jetzt im
vorhinein schon mal euch zeigen und
auspacken weil das sind nicht
irgendwelche sneaker das ist ein ganz
besonderes nica und zwar ich weiß ja
auch das so sagen kann aber
unzerstörbares liga praktisch also dass
und sneaker da kannst du mit auf nägel
laufen durch feuer reden ich weiß haben
wir das heute ausprobieren
wahrscheinlich besser nicht aber die
haben irgendwie so eine sch talsohle und
da habe ich mich dazu überreden lassen
diese einfach mal zu bestellen ich habe
es noch oft von euch gelesen dass heute
geschrieben haben alex check mal die
schuhe und hier sind sie auch schon
ich präsentiere euch dass wir sind
erstmal nicht nur die sind auch gar
nicht mal schlecht aus leute die haben
diese schuhe wartet weil man muss sagen
die schuhe mit eur 21 euro da kann man
nicht meckern
und wenn die dann auch noch so nägel
aushalten und so also das ist ja genial
da warst du noch bis 2 gemacht sind
das ist nämlich doch das was ich gedacht
hatte
bevor wir die dinge als dave ihre probe
stellen sagt man das so
schauen wir uns die erstmal auch an was
habe ich dadurch stellt gefälligst mit
zone gibt es hier hätte sowieso sagst du
dich als mike svoboda
achja einem dies stimmt designer genauso
aus das ist ja ein bisschen dumm kommt
man die sind einfach genau gleich aus
wer braucht bitte sowas fragt mich oder
dafür die baustelle die brusthöhle den
griff ich habe mich nie gefunden
startkarten sicherheits stiefel jogging
sneaker wandern paar schuhe pannensicher
und was noch weiter kann ich irgendwie
nicht lesen 100% nagelneu und hoher
qualität erster hinweis unsere größte
ist keine auszahlt wird ja klar aber gut
und hier dieses profil könnt ihr sehen
wir haben ja auch noch mehrere fotos sie
eigentlich rechts trifft aus dem fuß
guck mal genauer in verschiedenen farben
und was natürlich auffällt die sind
absolut nicht kaputt zu kriegen
ja so sieht das hier gerade auf dem
voraus und man soll damit vorüber nägel
laufen können und mit dem hammer drauf
schlagen
lasst doch so machen du fällst
vielleicht so von oben weist
bei hier oben ist ja in der ecke des
wurde mit dem hammer dann ist das case
of techno fans zu verwirken
und ich habe da auch wenn sehen merkel
möge alles rum hat ja ja ja ich muss
aber sagen wir können ja erst mal
anprobieren oder was ich auch noch ganz
kurz sagen könnte
die sind auch nicht besonders schwer
also vom gewicht her minimal schwerer
als hier diese wenn nicht sogar gleich
keine ahnung war zwar erst mal ab ob ihr
zu meinem outfit passen und ob man diese
tragen kann weil ich muss sagen also gar
nicht mal schlecht
meyer ist das ding ist manchmal manchmal
zu kurz wieder ausgewechselt
ja ich hab den rechten socken auf der
deutschen seite
jetzt sieht man ihm an
[Musik]
was ist denn hier und das ist das thema
das war da drin gehabt als
schlüsselanhänger
das ist sind chinesische zeichen darauf
rechten schlüsselanhänger juni kommt der
länder rheinseite diese ganzen sachen
aus china als sind manchmal solche
ministerien die sich darin verbergen
weil es machen wie man den ersten
überhaupt ist dass man hier immer so
fühlt sich eigentlich relativ bequem man
würde ich sagen
man merkt auf jeden fall dass sie
überall so ein bisschen stahl drumherum
ist oder was auch immer das ist aber
wenn du mich erzählen würdest würdest du
denken her was hat der vielen bilder
also eigentlich ganz normale sneaker
sorgen kann man auf jeden fall
[Musik]
wieso das finden wir denn ich wollte
dass zum start zu bringen so da kommen
jetzt zum partys ich tue es einmal
meinem fuß hier raus du kannst aber gute
freunde von mir hier ist vorbei
erstmalig mit der anderen seite
[Musik]
doch auch sparen oder so vorsichtig
nicht so fest
ja ja noch wenn ich da gibt's ja ja ja
noch stecke ja einmal auf aber nicht
suchen welt hat mamma hammer und nagel
rein mal gucken ob das funktioniert ich
muss ihn ja nicht angesehen hier nicht
bei jack ist oder nicht lässt sich nicht
an man halten dollar
ich glaube da geht es dann ich glaube
ich vor sich naja aber das letzte ist ja
gut und jetzt was man hier von unten den
nagel rhein fahren weil das soll wohl
nicht gehen also laut der
produktbeschreibung sollte dieser nagel
hier nicht rein kommen
komplett durch wo ist da ja ist durch
das durch er also vorsichtig
draußen haben wir hier ein weil das ist
ja mehr gefährlich oder nicht wenn die
stell dir vor das bestellt einer und
denkt sich auch da konnte ich alles
mitmachen das bringt dann auch den
regelgruppen und dann kannst du dein zum
schluss ja also was ist das denn
gebt euch mal das foto hier ja gut wenn
du auf einem nagelbrett läuft und so
nagl rein prügel star schon gut aber so
heftig war es jetzt auch nicht wenn du
150 kilo wiegt und einmal so macht er
aber auf einem nagelbrett kannst du auch
liegen
das heißt wenn man darüber lange ich
würde damit sollte man dann nicht werden
aber wird es ja gekauft ja genau das ist
jetzt eine anzeige aber vorne sollte
glaube ich kein nagel reinkommt
[Musik]
mehr kann ich sonst ja vorne ist das gut
gesichert hier unten nicht ich glaube
das ist wirklich nur ein sneaker mit
stolz also mit stahlkappe drin wie bei
diesem bauarbeiter schulen also dass
eigentlich nichts besonderes ich hätte
mich jetzt da eigentlich auf dem meer
gefreut
trotzdem war es ganz gut dass jetzt
einmal zu testen
damit ihr auch wisst leute wenn ihr
diesen schuh bestellt wolle man
ansonsten ganz wichtig schreibt auf
jeden fall weitere produkte die ich noch
bei solchen plattformen bestellen soll
in die kommentare
oder schreibt mir bei instagram die
frage ist jetzt soll ich diesen schuh
auch bei ins uferlose oder was mache ich
damit weil alles wieder letzten nagel
drin den kriegen wir noch ausnahmen und
dann verlor sich dann auch weil ich
brauche halt nicht wenn jemanden zu
haben möchtet ich weiß es jetzt nichts
krasses aber geht auf jeden fall auf
insta da wird immer alles verloren
antwortet mir dann einfach auf die story
läuft im schuh posten in laage kleine
raus und dann nimmt schon teil und
irgendwann kriegt das dann bekommt das
von mir zugeschickt besser als wenn wir
hier in der wohnung verkommen
naja so viel passieren aber nicht den
kanal aufnahmen wir sehen uns morgen
wieder um uns nur da gibt es ein neues
video
wenn ich mir jetzt erst mal fertig
beides von bush
[Musik]